floo states are states of heightened
focus that bring about enhanced reflexes
a sense of time dilation creative
problem-solving and a feeling of
infallible calm nootropics are
supplements medications and other
compounds used with the somewhat
transhuman goal of enhancing human
cognition to increase productivity and
performance seems like a match made in
heaven right as long-term discerning
viewers of this channel will know I'm
fascinated with both but also believe
that both have their issues that said in
this video I'll attempt to outline some
strategies for triggering and enhancing
flow through the use of nootropics I've
already done in-depth research into the
nature of flow which you can check out
in my previous to mastering ultra
instinct videos in this series likewise
as a written post that accompanies this
video that I'll link to in the
description down below there I explained
what a flow state is and what it isn't
and I take a look at some other popular
strategies for getting there like micro
dosing or using the hippie speedball I
also discuss why I think they're
misguided at best and dermat worst but
the Cliff Notes version it irritates me
and people described flow States as the
ultimate state of human performance
there's no one ultimate state the human
brain works best when it can change
between states quickly you wouldn't want
to be in a flow state when you were
trying to get to sleep a healthy brain
is one that's able to adapt that the
demands placed on it people like Steven
Kotler want to commodify flow States to
turn them into a panacea that can cure
every ailment searcher that they can
sell books and programs but in truth a
flow state is merely a state of intent
concentration on a particular task the
point where any task can become
meditative where you're so engrossed in
it that time appears to slow down and we
seem to be able to pull off feats or
would otherwise normally be lost to us
ideas come easily and reaction times
increase this is where the confusion
regarding transient hypofrontality comes
from I think this is the term that
describes the apparent shutdown of the
prefrontal cortex the default mode
Network and the sense of the self or ego
brain imaging shows that our forwards
planning and reflective areas close off
and we therefore lose that in a critic
that often distracts us from the task at
hand
many find this loss of self very
liberating and in fact seek flow States
as a kind of intoxication Freud would
describe this as the Thanatos instinct
that is to say that it seems some people
are just trying to escape themselves
turning flow States into an alternative
for things like alcohol that's not what
I'm interested in at all I speculate
that in fact we can achieve flow States
without shutting down the prefrontal
cortex entirely it simply depends on
what you are focused on if you focus on
surfing then of course that will mean
that you'll lose that in a voice you'll
be focused on balance and on the amazing
view around you not on what you had for
lunch but if you're 100% focused on
writing then I suspect that you'd see
less shutdown of these areas I've put it
to you that it's not hypofrontality that
causes flow but rather it's a symptom of
some forms of flow and indeed brain
scans of rappers in flow show that
specific areas of the prefrontal cortex
called the dorsal lateral prefrontal
cortex shuts down while the medial
prefrontal cortex remains active think
of flow more like brain efficiency then
if all it took for us to be in a state
of flow was hypofrontality then we'd be
in flow whenever we were highly stressed
as we know this is very far from being
the case and this is why we can't simply
rely on stimulants to get to flow either
in my previous research my conclusion
was that it was being in a state of calm
arousal that was more similar to flow
that means experiencing a sympathetic
response but maintaining your higher
brain function as needed it's the
difference between being psyched up and
being psyched out to that end
neuropeptide Y and DHEA might have a
role to play here so we know that
excitatory neurotransmitters like
dopamine norepinephrine play a role in
stimulating flow and we know that
serotonin which makes you feel good an
age of creativity might also be involved
things that I think might also play a
role though a neuropeptide Y and DHEA
DHEA buffers the effects of cortisol on
the hippocampus preventing that
prefrontal lobotomy feeling by allowing
us to still access our memories and
ideas even when we're highly stressed
neuropeptide Y or NP y on the other hand
is able to reduce the effects of
norepinephrine on the prefrontal regions
of the brain again helping us to
actually access the higher functions of
our brain whilst we're in a state of
heightened arousal it's also linked to
learning appetite and more studies show
that the top-performing elite athletes
in Special Operations personnel produce
more DHEA and npy chemicals in the face
of extreme stress and this is what sets
them apart from their peers it allows
them to perform better than most in
demanding situations and to thrive under
pressure when
go to pieces to stay focused despite
intense distractions so that's what you
need to know about flow without further
ado then here are some stacks that may
be able to encourage states of flow
keep in mind that I'm recommending
nothing simply discussing the topic of
interest and because it's cool caffeine
and l-theanine so this is one of the
oldest nootropics decks going and one of
the most popular and it's for good
reason to once you dive into it you'll
realize this is an almost perfect
synergistic combination for increasing
flow you'll know caffeine found in teen
coffee it works by blocking adenosine
receptors thereby reducing the groggy
effects of being awake too long
the wakefulness is then compounded by a
release of dopamine norepinephrine etc
all this boost concentration and focus
but it also risks making this jittery
and anxious and potentially reducing
creativity but that's where the
l-theanine comes in an amino acid that
occurs naturally in green tea alongside
caffeine and that's able to create a
relaxed state of focus l-theanine works
by blocking the effects of the highly
abundant excitatory neurotransmitter
glutamate this essentially prevents the
brain from going into an anxious
overdrive when it gets highly aroused
like caffeine it's also near protective
in the long term but what's perhaps the
most interesting thing about all this is
there also appears to help create alpha
and possibly theta brainwaves the
brainwaves associated with flow States
and meditation this is normally consumed
at a ratio of one to two that's 100
milligrams of caffeine to 200 milligrams
of theanine and from my experience it
certainly does help to elicit a state of
calm focus not that you can expect to
notice a radical difference adapt to 3 2
while researching this topic I came
across a number of different adaptogens
capable at least in theory of supporting
flow I started to craft a stack that I
was pretty excited by and was about to
unveil it and then I realized that it
was actually already a thing or at least
an extremely similar stack already
existed specifically I was accidentally
recreating a natural performance
boosting stack that was tested on elite
athletes astronauts and special
operatives in Russia before the days of
steroids called adapt to 3 to adapt to 3
to consist of Siberian ginseng aka
eleuthère Oh
rhodiola rosea and Cassandra geneticists
an adaptogen is a naturally occurring
herbal supplement with a rather vague
definition that being that it acts on
multiple pathways so rhodiola
Ziya is a traditional Chinese remedy
that acts on the adrenals and has anti
fatiguing properties
studies show that it's able to increase
tolerance to high pressure and
high-stress activities preventing
burnout in one study of 161 military
cadets it was found that it could
significantly boost mental work capacity
over placebos it's newer protective in
the long term and it works by elevating
dopamine and norepinephrine as well as
serotonin three of the neurotransmitters
identified as playing an important role
in flow in at least one study it's also
been shown to significantly increase
BDNF in the hippocampus Siberian ginseng
also known as le Theroux is not really a
ginseng at all but is actually a totally
different species of herb what it is is
another anti fatiguing agent that's been
shown to improve tolerance and
adaptation to novel stressors in
military personnel but again what I find
most interesting of all is the role it
might have in regulating the response to
stress via neuropeptide Y systems
Siberian ginseng actually appears to
increase many of the chemicals
associated with stress it helps the body
to better cope with them at the same
time cassandra is the odd one out here
this is a very bearing plant and a
cofactor that may help you to get more
from other nootropics it raises nitric
oxide there by aiding blood circulation
and in one study was found to reduce the
production of cortisol in athletes it
appears to help reverse stress induced
damage via changes to the monoamine
transmitters and plasma corticosteroid
it's also been suggested that may
enhance eyesight and night vision so I
tried this complete stack and found that
it did manage to increase my focus and
attention to a certain degree moreover
it seemed to help me cope with extremely
high workloads and the sleep deprivation
that comes from being a parent
unfortunately I also found that rhodiola
rosea in particular gave me a journey
stomach but it was this experiment that
also clued me in on to what the answer
might be for actually increasing flow
firerate nootropics tak vitamin d
omega-3 magnesium 3 and 8 a natural
gander with optional inositol creatine
lutein and curcumin so in my opinion
using nootropics to trigger flow is
misguided anything that can cause a
flood of one neurotransmitter will
artificially force you into one mental
state robbing you of the ability to
change gears as needed
instead we need to think about
supporting the brains natural ability to
get into flow by providing the health
and energy it needs the brain is
designed to produce excitatory
neurotransmitters when something
important is happening to thereby
enhance energy
enthusiasm focus creativity and reaction
times the problem is a when this is
accompanied by anxiety that makes it
hard for us to think and be that very
often we simply feel too tired and too
disinterested to summon this enthusiasm
so what's going on why can't you engage
with that important task and activate a
flow state focusing purely on the
physiological side of things for a
moment the answer may be to do with the
adrenal fatigue it's no secret that most
of us spend an inordinate amount of time
in a state of high arousal we're
stressed all the time by our alarm
clocks by our commute by looking at
computer screen by work but at the same
time we don't find any of this
particularly interesting so too many of
us suffer from adrenal fatigue and
craving something interesting and
entertaining so it's no wonder that we
struggled to summon our super human
focus at the office the next day or that
evening when training or starting in the
business so the best nootropic stack
should instead focus on recovering the
brain we should view this processes by
fasiq enhancing the recovery so that we
can go into the next day with the
optimal chance of attacking work with
plenty of energy and enthusiasm omega-3
fatty acid in your protective it'll
reduce inflammation it speeds up the
neuronal transmission through improved
cell membrane permeability and even
support neuroplasticity essentially
strengthening the connections between
brain cells plus more though as it also
helps to increase the production at the
HEA the hormone that helps to buffer the
effects of stress that we saw earlier
mister Mandi likewise helps to support
healthy levels of DHEA as well as
testosterone and other key hormones
magnesium supplementation is useful to
support the de midi supplementation but
can also encourage better sleep when
taking an evening and most importantly
to support neuroplasticity adaptogen
that we've seen are generally very
effective at helping the body to cope
with stress this is likely why I had
success with adapt to 3t as well as with
cordyceps a long time ago basically they
were just helping me to get back to my
baseline many of us are living with some
degree of burnouts and taking the time
to correct that can yield amazing
benefits safe or long-term support
astral gambler is a good choice because
it's been shown to raise DHEA levels and
lower cortisol by up to 26%
it also helped to regenerate axons and
dendrites reconstruct sign apses and
support BDNF production and there's
plenty more I'd add to a stack like this
including lutein creatine Kirk unit
cetera
but it starts to get a little bit
expensive include inositol that's listed
to is able to help boost the density of
neurotransmitter receptors the good news
is that all these ingredients except
maybe the ashwagandha they're easy to
get through your normal balanced diet
which is a very strong option they're
perfectly natural no side effects
instead of hacking the brain we're
simply ensuring that it has the
nutrients it's designed to thrive on in
order to better cope with the demands
were trying to place on it like I say
it's a biphasic approach a yin and the
yang and it also means the getting
proper rest is vitally important just
like you wouldn't expect to go extremely
hard in the gym every day without so
much as resting come evening and that's
why you can't just keep taking
stimulants try and boost yourself
further and further every single day
eventually that will just lead to
burnout so we aren't stimulating a flow
state so much as enhancing an adaptable
state from which flow should come much
more easily so I hope you found this
video useful and interesting guys
haven't done one on nootropics or flow
States for a while don't worry if you're
looking forward to that
Nightwing training part two that is on
the way I'll be here in the next couple
of weeks meanwhile I've got some other
learning from legends videos and some
cool tips on training lots more stuff if
that all sounds cool then thanks a ton
for watching and I'll see you next time
bye for now
you